hey everybody Sean McGinnis here with a
gamespot news update it's time to grab
your wallet because a steam summer sale
has officially begun for the next 11
days you'll be able to pick up tons of
new and classic games at a steep
discount if you're new to PC gaming or
have somehow missed it in the past
steams annual sale is the best time in
place to get those games you've been
meaning to check out daily deals are
updated every 24 hours at ten a.m.
pacific time although games usually
overlap and stay up for about 48 hours
and you often see discounts from fifty
percent to ninety percent off the sale
is kicking off with the witcher 2 for
all of four dollars far cry 3 4 750 and
mirrors edge for five dollars if you
don't see anything interesting at first
keep checking back there are flash sales
which only lasts eight hours before
getting refreshed and community choice
sales which allow voting on the next set
of games to go on sale which also change
every eight hours valve has also
included a minigame in their sale called
the summer adventure that allows you to
earn badges points and in-game items you
may want to check out other sites such
as Amazon before you purchase they often
compete directly with steam sales so
what are you most excited to buy this
year what games did you buy last year
and never even touch let us know in the
comments